[Applause]
other dead thanks we appreciate I
appreciate being here I proceed being in
Toronto at the great town today I spent
the day going to the museum and visiting
so I really enjoying the city I'm going
to start with a story
it's March 2015 and I'm driving I'm
going to pick up my children at some
friends house on a Friday night and it's
about half an hour drive from settling
in and I'm listening to the CBC like I
usually do what a particular evening the
content is not usually what you get on
the CBC so on the air is this University
of Toronto professor and what he's
saying rings with it off from what I
usually hear on that show a first he's
talking about religions and religious
symbolism and he's doing it in a way
let's say he's doing it without the
usual smugness that we tend to hear when
people talk about religion especially
about Christianity so here you're
talking about Christianity but I can
tell he's not a I'm not a priest there's
not a a preacher he's a psychologist you
defined it and so I could talk unfold my
attend my attention heightened and after
a few minutes just a few minutes I just
I can't believe what I am hearing as
this process going through stories of
Adam that he's chained a table jumping
and Shakespeare and Milton and jerking
and then to Darwin and Nietzsche and
young and and immediately I see what
he's doing
he isn't just trying to communicate
information she's dancing across this
wide variety of references because what
he wants to do is he wants to bring out
he wants to trace this underlying
pattern
and by doing so he's trying to awaken
something in his listeners he's not just
trying to get them to understand which
is what you usually hear when you listen
to talks no he's trying to provoke try
to shake people into experiencing how
the world is built with meaning he talks
about logos which is true meaning
expressed in word the search for purpose
and logos transformed transformed chaos
and potentiality into being and in
opposition to this lies deceit
resentment gradually dismantle the world
and plunge it into ever-growing channel
it of course you've taken this from the
Bible the book of Genesis from the
Gospel of st. John sprinkled with some
phenomenology but he's very clearly
describing this process at all levels of
reality at the individual the
interpersonal the social political level
and its interaction between logos and
chaos is the main manner you could say
by which the world is constantly
sustained so by this point I am
literally cheering in the car I'm like
I'm [ __ ] my period and all I can
think is who is this who is this person
talking and why have I not heard of him
before like why is he not famous I guess
you don't ask that question anymore
right
and especially I'm like how does he know
this you see like so the attempt to help
people see experience pattern meaning
and religious symbol is on how it
connects to all levels of reality that's
what I've been trying to do for years
that's my goal in life I would say my
carvings in my articles in my talk so I
okay there's only a handful of people
that I know that I can relate to at that
level and then it's not that people
don't talk about religious symbolism
actually a lot of people do but usually
when you hear people talk about
religious symbolism at some point you
can kind of picture them in like a
tinfoil hat and then you know they soon
extraterrestrials become part of the
discussion but not this guy he's just as
clear as can be so when I get home so I
reach out to him
and I send him just a little message you
know just thanking him and my expressing
my surprise and linking into a few few
articles I had written a few talks I
didn't you know that was it I didn't
expect I didn't really expect an answer
but then the next morning I get I get a
message thanking me for my message and
pointing me to a few lectures that he
had given more specifically on religion
I thought that's pretty cool like that
that's nice this random Quebecers
sending messages to him but then about
it about an hour and a half later I get
this call and I can't do this I can't do
this
anyway it's my memories my memories of
that moment are kind of vague but I
think I probably acted like a 14 year
old meeting Kanye West or something
and now his tone is one of surprise
maybe a bit of confusion and is 80
questions and he's announcing an
expected end the sentence how do you
know that because he'd listened to my
talk and he saw the relationship between
what I was saying and what he was saying
in the Talk That Talk about how Lobos
organizes potential into experience
beans and so why why am I telling you
this
I mean first of all I'm telling this as
an excuse because despite what father
Ted says here's this Carver who's
standing among theologians and
professors though the reason why I'm
here because since then professor
Peterson and I have developed it's dis
relationship some of you might have seen
the interviews that you did together but
mostly I'm telling you this because I
know I know that it nears the story of
so many people that are probably here in
this room and a lot of the people that
might hear this on YouTube were in the
podcast I know that it nears it I know
because dozens of people have told me of
that experience you know it I I have an
image and I know people have seen it of
Joe Rogan hearing dr. Peterson talk for
the first time and his jaw dropping you
know I had all of a sudden she sees
religion in a completely different way
and I'd even received dozens of message
from I would call those in protest
atheist who say you know my questions
and my thinking have been tilted
slightly in unexpected ways and that
experience I think has been strongest
for Orthodox Christians like myself in
fact I stopped counting the number of
messages I received from priest asking
me soap so dr. Pearson Orthodox
and to which I usually answer no he just
likes off the FG a lot and there is even
one clergy clergyman who who answered to
that at all yeah he's orthodoxy just
doesn't know it yet but this correlation
has been persistent so what is this
connection what made the connection
between a traditional Christian like
myself and dr. Peterson so obvious so
immediate and all of this I believes
resolves around the notion of logos the
language of logos is the underlying
language of Christianity of course we
know the first vision of logos in
Christianity comes from the Gospel of
st. John in the beginning was the logos
the logos was with God and the logos was
God he was in the beginning with God and
through him all things were made without
him nothing was made that has been made
in him was life and that life was the
light of all mankind that light shines
in the darkness and the darkness has not
overcome it and this vision of logos
would be continued and develop in the
life of the church and especially in the
seventh century there was a saint
his name is st. Maximus the Confessor
and he really brought this image of
logos I would say to its most detailed
or most elaborate digit and he did so by
taking the notion of logos that was in
the New Testament and he he brought and
United it with the best of what the
Western tradition had already offered he
was able to prune let's say what it come
from philosophy and enjoying it with
what the Christian method was so that it
would attain some clarity and maybe some
details
and so 10 Maximus explains that all
things have a logos which are because
its reason for existence its purpose and
its origin all at once and even its ends
with all those things at once and on top
of that each thing has a multitude of
Logie that's a word she's probably never
heard before
loki is the plural of logos and so the
LOI
they're like the different qualities of
things so the blueness of the glue or
the slowness of the slow and all of
these logos are brought together they're
woven together we could say it sustained
the existence of the world it's really a
map of meanings to use various words
now these Logie these essences that say
of things they don't exist independently
in the same way that scientists believe
things exist out there rather they exist
as they come together as they are joined
together in our encounter with the world
in a pattern you could say so we could
say for example like that a sunset has a
certain amount of low heat maybe even
indefinite amounts of characteristics of
a sunset but as they come together to be
the experience of the sunset that's how
we experience reality that's how we
become into contact with reality so all
these qualities is a light colored
vertical horizontal and the thing needs
the Sun the sky the earth all of these
things and I could go on there's an
indefinite amount of them what's
important in making that experience real
is how all those Yogi's are united so
and in a way they're united within us
and human beings for 10 Maximus are seen
as this laboratory where the whole world
finds
cohesion and he expresses it in the
sense that the human being is a
microcosm to say a condensation of the
cosmos so the place where the cosmos
comes together to make sense and a good
way to see it is is that human beings
actually participate being in the image
of God they participate in creation we
see that in the book of Genesis the book
of Genesis God tells Adam to name the
animals and so by his logo participating
in a limited way in the same manner that
the divine logos was the source of
everything and the human participation
in this process is not a relativistic
thing it's not an individual thing I
mean though it is flexible it's
nonetheless the most objective of
processes as father Ted mentioned and so
we need to be conscious though because
they Maximus warns us that it's not just
a philosophy or it's not just a
technical description of the world this
is important because thinking that
religious stories are exactly the same
kind of encyclopedic knowledge of modern
science is the wrong way to go witness
these logos the truth about things are
our categories of our engagement listen
look but maybe today we might call them
phenomena spent phenomenological
category and so this is subtree of truth
of logos it's a personal journey
it's simultaneously a refinement of our
understanding of the world but at the
same time it becomes the refinement of
our person so to discover the true
nature of things is to walk on a task of
truth so food is a wonderful thing and
it's useful for life but gluttony leads
to our instruction well is useful to
accomplish important things but average
plus the soul so you see it's not just a
description of the world it's a path
that walk as we discover the world and
so sin and decision of the world at
horrible world is that horrible words
that no one wants to hear sin isn't just
the breaking of arbitrary rule but it
it's in the misuse of the world and that
misuse of the world ends up being an
untruth ends up being a liar or
something that's false something that
separates things from each other it's
found when things are not aligned with
their purposes so for example a person
is not only a tool for my own
gratification person is not just a tool
for that I can advance myself in the
world and if I treat a person
exclusively like that then I will
inevitably sin against that person and
of course it doesn't mean that a person
cannot act as a tool for my
gratification if I go see the Baker and
I get bread from him he's the method by
which I get my bread but the Baker is
not just a baker he he is a full person
just as myself so when we steal or rely
or we cheat it's because we're not
considering to hate the person facing us
to be a full-blown person to be what
they are according to their logos but we
see them only as limited things only a
tool so this is true of people of things
and of actions so I was thinking about I
was trying to think about the best
example that I could think of to to show
this in terms of actinin and I thought
of giving the example of upset so we did
the metaphysics of Pepe so I think we
can get away with a metaphysics of fact
I hope but it's a question that
definitely needs to be answered today in
our topsy-turvy times I say so what is
the logos of sexuality well it has many
low-heat many purposes
for the propagation of the species I
hope at least a few of you still think
that despite what many people would want
us to believe creates families and
communities it brings two people
together and the type of communion in an
expression of love and it's very
pleasant those global meetings would be
some of the lobby I'm sure we could find
more but some those would be summable
only that section exists and there could
be more
but the idea in division of logos is
that all those things need to be brought
together in a pattern of some sort for
them to be a path towards logos so if we
think of the different loci and we bring
them together trying to think of the
word what does that work when we also
think this together I think we have a
word factoring of the church I'll let
you figure it out what it is when all
those things come together and so each
of the separate purposes of sex that I
mentioned they're not wrong they're fine
but they become alive when we bring them
together if we don't that each separate
purpose appears as a kind of falsehood
it appears as kind of lacking so that's
not enough let's say for truly
traditional or a truly complete vision
of sexuality it cannot end it has to
move towards the infinite it has to move
toward God and so the ultimate logos of
sexuality is to be an image of the
mystical union God and it's to be an
image of our union with that with what
is beyond us I mean that image of the
mystical union of God with the soul with
Christ with his church the marriage of
heaven and earth is a completely
traditional image that we find in in the
church fathers or in our tradition
and so that's that image of the ultimate
Union the highest union with the
infinite then it comes back down into
the multiple Logan all those other
reasons for sexuality that I mentioned
and it builds them it makes them
participate in the transcendent compass
and becomes the very relationship that
binds them together and everything in
our life is follow that project work who
sleep duty and to engage the world in
that frame is is to find light
everywhere to see life everywhere the
world is no longer made of the dead
lifeless dirt the dead lifeless material
that we used to make things with and as
we become better as people more truthful
more grateful more free as we come
closer to one another in love and by the
way that's what love is love is the
manner in which all different things all
different people all different
intentions can join together and exist
in communion and can become one while at
the same time preserving the
multiplicity because we follow the task
the hidden Logie in creation they shine
through the world and today we might say
that they Rhian sense the world and the
world is right and full and not the gray
and dead shadows we often lived in that
would be I hope a summary success of
that path is local but I haven't really
explained what the source of my
excitement was on that Friday night yet
what the source of the excitement was
that had caused all this flurry of
attention to Jordan and I can tell you
I've been thinking about this now for
months now I mean some of us and Jordan
isn't thinking about this for
month now and I I think by now we can
say that it's really not about gender
pronouns it's not it's about something
is a lot bigger than that and I think I
can say confidently by now that it's
about logos the entire project or
post-modernism the last 30 40 years of
higher culture and higher education has
been systematic assaults on logos to
dissenter
logos to deconstruct narratives and
value heritage so we are left slipping
and sliding without purpose and
direction and now we've reached the end
of what post-modernism has to offer you
can actually say that in come to a point
where post-modernism has won basically
the cultural debate and a philosophy
which decried the center and certain
certainty has prodigiously become the
very center and unquestionable Authority
despises so everything is upside down
everything is inside out everything is
becoming its opposite and all these
inversions and chaos are not to be taken
lightly it has brought about a sterile
age literally sterile as people are not
having enough children to to fill the
society I think I keep thinking that
maybe they're missing a bit of foul
sentience
but it's also sterile and that it has
brought about this narcissistic and
fragmented culture you see they told us
that the center cannot hold and how they
fall apart and now everybody is decrying
the end of truth all of a sudden right
everybody is saying that we're entering
an age of post truth fake news I mean my
goodness they even used it in as an
argument against us
Peterson the debate on gender pronoun
and it's the postmodernist that heralded
the end of truth 40 years ago and now
they're surprised to see the
effectiveness how chaos does not
discriminate how it's turning against
them just as they turned it against
their ideological enemies they wanted to
change the world to stand now they're
surprised to find it slipping between
the fingers what is most surprising what
is most shocking to them is to find that
now having reached the end of their
pursuit having thought they had won
Dickey from within the decomposing
residue of Western patriarchy they see
that there is a seed that sprouted that
in the darkest place there is a flame
that is lips logos awaken the darkness
has not overcome it and John promises
that my postmodern friends if you had
just paid attention to the story
she had just paid attention to the
stories which are woven in the fabric of
our consciousness
these vary stories he tried to
deconstruct you would have noticed that
Don always comes that a seed is always
planted their logos regains the centers
Christ rises from the dead and I think
that's the excitement we're feeling
right now to find that small spark that
seed of a meaningful pattern surprising
us in a collapsing world and it's not
just a pattern of meaning but it's the
beginning of a network of people and
just in the past two years there's a
whole new strange group of public
figures that's arising from the margin
people who are at least trying to figure
it out who are least trying to see
clearly and work out ideas and people
who are as different from each other
as you can imagine spanning across
gender race and cultures even religious
that atheist delight
to figure it out and get the media and
the activists they scream sterically
bigoted racist sexist not be all the
usual litany of attacks and they're
losing their minds the sand is slipping
out of their hands and it's only two
years ago we would have probably
collapsed before this attack but now you
look around and we find that there is a
still silent Center in which the sand
and you stand there is an eye the
overwhelming hurricane and we can
finally say we will not accept your
frame we will not accept your definition
they are weak by the very process you
use to deconstruct them to deconstruct
the category and we will speak for
ourselves what a relief
but it is a dangerous time the time of
transition the time of chaos is a
dangerous time firstly because the
enemies of logos will ramp up their
hysteria and totalitarian tendencies as
logos awaken but it is also dangerous
because as Christ himself told us the
chairs grow among the weak the reefs
entering of logos is the reawakening of
identities who can't avoid them another
frightening things because if identity
stops at the relatively low heat without
aiming without uniting itself to the
highest of high it can be murderous and
it has been increasingly murderer just
in the past century and it is in fact a
very murderous and genocide o tendency
of identity which provoked the
postmodern to deconstruct identity in
the first place and there's a part where
we can't blame them for that
I mean in the shadow of house with what
else can you do so what will strive from
this new sprout will depend on us will
depend on all of us
what will rise from this chaos we've
seen exciting exciting but also
frightening possibilities of what that
might look like we will it be rate again
so that we inch towards genocide which
is only the nation so we're tempted to
revisit the world wars well that only be
gender would only be class and the
scheme's run out for us bison Maximus
the ultimate identity the plate for all
meaning finds its resolution is the
divine mobile the source of everything
that is our trajectories as we walk the
path of logos as we are transformed by
truth the finality is to be united with
God and I know that for some people just
the word God causes allergic reaction
and I'm sure people listening to this
will be developing highest on the skin
as they they hear this but maybe we can
just think of it this way for identity
to be more than a weapon it must reach
its highest point in something that is
beyond two hours and so finding seeing
our highest identity in God is finding
unity with everything and the source of
everything and in terms of Christianity
is particular the identity was Christ is
different from other identity because
it's the identity was a cross he needs
to identify with suffering and it's not
the identity of a self-serving power but
the identity of a self-emptying power
power found in love that empties itself
out of love I mean it doesn't mean that
we shouldn't struggle doesn't mean that
you should just lay down and give up
that you should let our enemies destroy
what we value most mean Christ Vox
brought a whip into the temple after
but what it really entails with what was
important about it and this is something
that is echoed for founding with dr.
Peterson has been telling us that we
must first walk on the path of logos
ourselves he must embrace our own
suffering in that truth we must take up
our cross we must do so with the desire
to first get rid of the lives with blind
eyes to strengthen our own path and in
doing so well that is how we will change
the world
since terra firma sorrow is known to
obsess save yourself and thousands
around you will be faced as we walk on
that path as we strip away our own
excesses rather than look rather than
looking at the imbalances of others as
you strip away our bad habits and our
narcissism rather than acting like
victims throat will change and you will
start to feed and to experience logos to
fully live within the patterns of
meaning to constitute the world if you
take that journey I guarantee that the
universal patterns of meaning will
manifest themselves so strongly in your
life that at first you'll use the word
synchronicity but soon you'll have no
other word to use the sighs miracle the
postmodern chaos is vanish has wax melts
before fire and logos very logos that
rises from the grave will fill your
world and be worlds with life and life
[Applause]